Make sure you guys hit the subscribe button.
If you guys are enjoying the content that we're throwing up and make sure you
guys hit the like button, if you enjoyed the video and yeah, let's begin.
All right. What's going on guys.
Rob and a credit goes to aunt here for this one. Uh,
aunt is a fan on the, um, on the discord server who hit me up and said,
Hey man, there is a change in Marvel comics about Franklin Richards.
And I was like, okay, let's take a look at this and let's see what's going on.
Right? So this comes out on the newest issue of fantastic four issue number 26.
And here's the funny thing for people who don't know the history of Franklin
Richards,
they're freaking out for people who do know the history about Franklin Richard's
it's like, yeah, that kind of makes sense. It was always kind of that way. Okay.
So one of the big changes they made here is there's a point in the story whereby
Franklin is trying to find a way back to Precoa and he's met by Charles Xavier.
Who's reading his mind and Charles Xavier says, no,
you cannot come back to Coca-Cola.
And when Franklin asked the reason why Charles says,
because you're not a mutant, right? According to Cerebro,
you never have been one that as a child, you dreamed of being different,
special without intending to you used your cosmic powers to alter every cell in
your own body, until it appeared as if you possess the XG.
And so basically he made himself into look like a mute, right?
You just kind of masqueraded himself more or less,
but he is not inherently a mutant. This is an accurate statement. And in fact,
it kind of comes from two different sources. Now it wasn't until, well,
we'll talk about whether that changed here in a minute. So, uh,
wind the clock back here, right? One o'clock back to fantastic.
Four annual number six and fantastic for issue. Number 103 now fantastic.
Four annual number six was written by Stanley and Jack Herby and issue one Oh
three was written by Stan Lee and drawn by John, uh, John Romita.
But the idea behind this was that in annual number six,
that's when Franklin was going to be born. Right.
And what you ended up finding out was that there were complications that
seemingly the power, the August, the cosmic energy that gave, uh,
Susan and Reed and those guys, their energy,
or give them their powers was effectively being siphoned off by Franklin, right?
In the same way that, you know,
a woman eats food and the baby kind of consumed it. If she doesn't eat enough,
it'll cause problems for her,
it was basically the same thing with regards to the energy she had.
And so in order to bounce those energy levels out,
what Reed and Johnny and Ben Grimm did is they traveled to the negative zone and
then grabbing something called the cosmic control rod.
And the cosmic control rod is an artifact in the negative zone.
That's in possession of a guy named the nihilists that allows its user to
basically wield cosmic energy and the most extreme degree, right.
To basically control the fundamental laws of the universe itself.
An ILS uses it for his own personal own personal benefit, right?
So like keeping himself young, different things like that.
But when a portion of that energy was siphoned off by Reed and it was brought to
the main Marvel universe and given to Susan that in fantastic for anyone,
number six, a portion of that energy passed onto Franklin.
And it basically meant the Franklin was born with the ability to alter matter on
a universal scale to alter matter on the atomic and subatomic level.
Now in fantastic four issue, number 103,
he was handed over to Agatha Harkness and in issues one Oh four, one Oh five,
one Oh six and one Oh seven, it was kind of established.
The Franklin just sort of had these powers as a result of the cosmic control
rod, but all that changed fantastic for issue number 130,
when the team's facing off against the frightful four and the frightful four has
some campaign where they're trying to get a hold of Franklin and it's
established the Franklin as a mutant for the very first time and Marvel comics
following that establishment from that point, going forward,
Marvel always referred to Franklin as a Newton.
So you had the original source of his powers and Marvel changed it and issue
130, it remained the status and it has been ever since,
and we've seen it in multiple sources, right? You see it in house, an ex,
you saw it in a, what is it X-Men fantastic. Four or whatever it was.
You saw it in X-Men unlimited. Number 14, back in the day,
you saw it and decimation that decimation storyline, the one 98 one-shot comic,
that was like a list of all the mutants who were out there that are left and
like the most powerful ones and Franklin was listed among them.
What happened now in this particular story,
Marvel basically undoing everything that's happened since fantastic four annual
number six, and basically going back to the original content.
So I guess it's true that like they're making a great, big,
huge rec Connor baby huge change, but not necessarily.
They're setting things back to the way they used to be.
And that's the big difference here.
What you're seeing here is tantamount to like when captain America,
Steve Rogers lost his super soldier serum.
He passed the mantle on to Sam Wilson who became the new captain America.
And then Steve Rogers regained a super soldier serum and went back to being
captain America again. Right.
It's a return to the way things used to be the difference here is that a lot of
people don't know this history about Franklin.
And so in their mind is not necessarily okay.
Marvel setting things back to the way they used to be back during like the
sixties and seventies. Yeah. And their mind is mobile, just changing things,
Willy nilly. And it's not to say anything wrong with that.
It's just not knowing the history of the character,
but that's the way those things work. You know,
that's the way that Marvel comics works. Marvel comics introduces something.
They'll change things up later on.
The important thing to understand about this is that this is the end of Dan
slots, Ron, as far as I'm aware,
I think we get like a whole new writer and everything at this point.
So likely this won't stay this way forever. And in fact,
it'll probably go back to things, being a certain way.
The thing about Franklin is the fact that he was a mutant never really mattered
in Marvel comics.
It was never really a relevant thing because you never really saw him doing
things in comics that could only be done because he was a mutant,
his ability to go to cacoa, which is where all the mutants are located at.
And only mutants can go there.
The only reason why him being a mutant mattered was because of that story.
But when you go look at things like heroes, reborn, where all this,
all the superheroes,
except for like the X-Men and Spider-Man died in a fight against onslaught,
which was when,
like the mind of Magneto and the mind of Xavier merged into a singular being
Franklin Richard's resurrecting them all from the dead and putting them in a
universe that he created of his own accord had nothing to do with the fact that
he was a mutant when Abraxis was free, right.
This representation of like destruction across the multi-verse,
whatever it was that he was.
And Abraxis started killing every version of Galactus from across the collar,
across the multi-verse when Franklin Richards resurrected Galactus from the dead
and that story,
it had nothing to do with the fact that he was a mutant when he resurrected
Galactus from the dead and made him into his Harold during Heckman's run,
it had nothing to do with the fact that he was a mutant.
So I don't really understand that people are kind of getting upset about that.
The fact that he's a mutant is irrelevant in the face of all the things he's
done, because it never had anything to do with anything. Right.
It was never a focal point of that particular story. I mean,
at the end of the day, you know, it's just a thing that he happened to be,
but it's, it's, it's intriguing to me.
I'm kind of curious to see where Marvel goes, but at the same time,
I don't really care because again, it was never really anything that mattered.
All I cared about with Franklin was the fact that he could just do cool stuff,
right? That's all I cared about.
That's the only thing that matters to me and the, the,
the fan theory that he controls the Marvel universe feels you guys,
you don't know what that means. There is this fan theory.
That's been circling a circulating around for a number of years that if you go
and you look at the publication history of Marvel comics,
that Marvel always referenced current events, right?
Like there's stories where the fantastic four meet with like Richard Nixon and
stuff like that, who is a president at the time. And a lot of those stories.
And then when fantastic,
four annual number six happened that coincided with the publication of Marvel
ceasing to reference modern day events, right?
It was away from Marvel to kind of sustain suspend disbelief and just kind of
say, well, comics happen at any point in time,
but because of the fact that Marvel stopped referencing current events after
Franklin Richards was born,
then it led to this fan theory that Franklin Richards is the reason why no one
ages, he's a reason why everybody is the same,
because Franklin would have these moments in his youth when he would use his
powers, like age himself, up into an adult, different things like that.
He would make some slight alterations or some big alterations,
but he wouldn't really know what he was doing. And that on a subconscious level,
Franklin wants everything to stay the way that it is that Franklin doesn't want
things to change. Right?
So like the most hardcore of hardcore comic book fans and the results of this is
that Franklin uses powers unwittingly and basically froze the entirety of the
Marvel universe. So that's why Spider-Man, isn't like six years old right now.
Right? I mean, which would make sense. He probably be older than that.
Like he was a teenager when he first got his power. So fast forward, 40,
50 years CB in his seventies, if we were following in real time,
that's why those things haven't happened because Franklin Richards
subconsciously doesn't want them to be that way.
And so he keeps things the way that they're,
that the way that we're used to just a fan theory, I think is a really cool one.
But hopefully this kind of explains what's going on.
Apparently a lot of people on Twitter are freaking out,
but this makes sense to me. Right. I'm okay with this. It makes perfect sense.
It's just going back to the original history of Franklin Richards back in
fantastic four annual number six, the way he was originally created,
which is fine because at the end of the day, whether he's a mutant or not,
it doesn't matter.
He's still a ridiculously overpowered character and can do pretty much anything
he wants to in the universe. So with that being said, guys,
we're gonna bring this video to an end.
If you are new here to come and explain to make sure you guys have the sub
button to become part of the rod port. If you guys enjoyed this video,
make sure you drop a light and that will catch you all in.
[Inaudible].